[Musik]
und jetzt das heute schon mit heinz wolf
und marietta slomka
guten abend wieder ein kriegstag in der
ukraine an dem aber auch die diplomatie
sich weiter versucht auf höchster ebene
der israelische ministerpräsidenten
after librettist überraschend nach
moskau geflogen und hat wohl immerhin
drei stunden lang mit putin gesprochen
danach ist er direkt weiter nach berlin
geflogen und redet jetzt zur stunde mit
kanzler schulz dazu kommen wir später in
der sendung noch blicken jetzt aber
erstmal auf das geschehen in der ukraine
dominik löschmeister berichtet
mutiger widerstand in einer besetzten
stadt es sind hunderte die in carson
gegen die russischen besatzer auf die
straße gehen erst vor drei tagen hatten
russische truppen die hafenstadt
eingenommen der zehnte kriegstag in der
ukraine und russland erhöht den
militärischen druck an verschiedenen
orten schwer umkämpft seit tagen die
strategisch wichtige hafenstadt mario
polen das russische
verteidigungsministerium
hatte am morgen eine feuerpause
angekündigt damit zivilisten mario pohl
und die nördlich gelegene vorstadt wo
nova verlassen können
doch die gefechte gehen weiter die
evakuierung stockt beide seiten geben
sich die schuld dafür
uns ist klar geworden die russische
seite hat nicht wort gehalten
sie machen weiter und zerstören mario
pohl wir haben beschlossen unsere
bevölkerung zurückzuholen auf den
straßen ist es nicht sicher
der russische außenminister sieht die
verantwortung hingegen bei der ukraine
wir hören heute auf social media dass
die behörden von mario pohl sich weigern
den bewohnern die möglichkeit zu geben
über den vom russischen militär
eingerichteten humanitären korridor
auszureisen
es ging
schwer umkämpft auch die stadt ihre pin
westlich der hauptstadt kiew
immer wieder detonationen und einschläge
viele fliehen überwiegend frauen und
kinder sind es die versuchen über eine
zerstörte brücken aktiv zu gelangen der
präsident in seiner täglichen botschaft
heute ist samstag während des krieges
samstag ein wort das fast nichts
bedeutet
hier versammeln sich junge männer um in
den krieg zu ziehen gerade mal 20 jahre
sie
studiere wirtschaft ich biologie
stadt an die universität geht es an die
front mitten in europa die stimmung
wirkt heiter doch sie wissen nicht was
sie erwartet
der russische präsident der weißem tee
mit piloten und flugbegleiterinnen der
fluggesellschaft aeroflot
putin übt scharfe kritik an den
westlichen sanktionen und er warnt vor
einer flugverbotszone über der ukraine
jede bewegung in diese richtung wird von
uns angesehen als eine beteiligung in
diesem bewaffneten konflikt von welcher
seite auch immer es stellt eine
bedrohung für unsere streitkräfte da
der krieg in der ukraine
er wird immer gefährlicher auch für
journalisten ein team des britischen
senders sky news unter beschuss
ein reporter wird verletzt wie durch ein
wunder gelingt ihnen die flucht
dass kiew zugeschaltet ist und alexej
minis politikwissenschaftler hat eine
zeit lang auch in münster studiert und
promoviert guten abend ist der mini und
gleich die frage wie geht's ihnen
sitzen in kiew sind sind abends im
luftschutzkeller oder wie schützen sie
sich
jetzt will ich zu hause eigentlich sie
hatten ja uns verabredet für dieses
gespräch wir zeichen dass jetzt auch auf
also wir haben jetzt hier in deutschland
17 uhr 20 in kiew 18 und 20 weil sie
sagten wenn es ein kiew so ab 19 uhr
wird es dort schlimmer das heißt es wird
vor allen dingen am abend geschossen und
bombardiert oder wie versöhnlich das
verstehen eigentlich ist gestern das war
tatsächlich die lage seit 24 heberer das
war immer so von a bis z von achse 19
uhr da eigentlich man könnte sogar durch
geschlossene fenster
was hier los ist oder ihn bezirke
nebenbei irgendwelche beschlüsse bomba
regierung und so etwas aber seit gestern
ist die lage ein bisschen besser ich
weiß nicht ob es tatsächlich ein zeichen
für gewisse
verbesserung ist oder vielleicht ist es
seine stille vor dem sturm buchstäblich
also zum beispiel der versuch in kiew
komplett einzukesseln
ja obwohl muss ich sagen das ist
überhaupt nicht dirigieren bis heute
viel mehr wenn es tatsächlich ihn ersten
tag in die kiste richtung gerne waren
von morgen von westen da ist die lage so
die verteidigung zeigt sich ich meine
grenze verteidigung sich gut und die
russin überhaupt nicht durch sie haben
ja auch eine zahl die ukrainische
regierung beziehungsweise den nationalen
sicherheits- und verteidigungsrat
beraten sind direktor des politik
instituts für globale transformation
also sie kennen sich halt auch mit
solchen strategischen fragen aus sind
sie hoffnungsvoll dass es gelingt kiew
zu halten und vor allem auch die
regierung im amt zu halten und wenn
nicht was passiert dann
wir werden gewinnen weil es gegen das
hat niemand gewonnen und wir haben
eigentlich jahrhundert land mit den
russen erfahrung wenn es zu direkten
auseinandersetzung kommt bekommen wir
wissen überhaupt nichts gutes
und deshalb holte sich die lage so
einerseits realistisch ich erwarte noch
die zweite welle militärische angriffe
vielmehr
bombardieren von der luft
ländliche offensive in gewissem recht
stellt insbesondere im süden und muster
aber
jedes osten von russland
sind nicht sogar viel mehr sie haben
fasst etwa bist du 80 prozent von alle
diese große armeen oder alle diese
armeen von russische grenze und bürger
russische grenze schon in der ukraine
verbraucht oder eingesetzt und was haben
sie recht mit allen diesen gruppierungen
nicht besonders viel und deshalb es gibt
zwei möglichkeiten entweder die zweite
welle und eigentlich der letzte versuch
etwas zu großes zu erreichen sei es
hauptsächlich zum beispiel hier oder
hier zu besetzen um als zeichen zu
setzen wir haben die souveräne
durchgeboxt oder wenn es noch
irgendwelche für sie
heißt hier putin oder andere leute
bleibt in moskau dringend tatsächlich de
facto zum tisch zu sitzen um zuerst über
eigentlich sieg feiern zu retten
daher passen ja vorher pause und dann
eigentlich wieder gewisse
regelung friedensverhandlungen um so
etwas und da können ziemlich viele
westliche partner und nicht nur
westliche fragte eigentlich auch mit
hilfe der mini wir haben ja in den
berichterstattungen über die ukraine
immer so am vor diesen krieg das gefühl
gehabt dass im osten und nicht nur im
don was doch ein sehr starker anlehnung
zu russland ist dass viele ukrainer sich
auch russland seriennah fühlen darauf
setzt ja auch immer putin wenn er sagt
das ist unser bruder volk hat da jetzt
durch diese bombardierungen ein
kompletter stimmungsumschwung
stattgefunden das also auch ukraine die
sich eigentlich russland sehr zugehörig
fühlten da jetzt ganz anders empfinden
es waren
ausgenommen ausgenommen vielleicht ging
um gewisse bezirken 1 group ist muss man
zugeben aber nach 2004 und die leute
sind ganz praktisch überall in der welt
sie gucken auf ganz praktische sachen
überleben und dann haben sie ziemlich
schnell verstanden worum es geht so
genannten brackets russische welt und
das mochte man überhaupt nicht egal
welche märchen aus gram will man weiter
strahlte und strahlt bis heute
festnehmen ich danke ihnen sehr dass es
die zeit genommen haben für das gespräch
und wir wünschen ihm von herzen alles
gute achten sie gut auf sich dank ihnen
alles gute und
anderthalb millionen menschen sollen
bereits aus der ukraine geflohen sein
aber auch innerhalb der ukraine flüchten
menschen aus den besonders hart
umkämpften gebieten dorthin wo es noch
keine so heftigen bombardements gibt vor
allem nach lewis auf deutsch lemberg
ganz im westen des landes von dort
reisen viele weiter nach polen oder
bleiben armen karpaty lemberg mit jungen
ukraine angesprochen die dort gestrandet
sind
körperlich ist er in form fit stark und
gesund doch sascha will nicht in den
krieg zu hause in rocky frei auf der
artistenschule jetzt ist er vor dem
bombenhagel nach lemberg geflüchtet und
sollte sich zum kampf melden
es heißt jeder der hier in lemberg
ankommt muss ein gewehr nehmen und das
land verteidigen ich habe aber angst
davor und will einfach dieser propaganda
nicht glauben dass jedermann für sein
land sterben muss
sascha ist pazifist und für die ist
gerade wenig platz in der ukraine erst
mal ist in einer schule untergekommen
weil wir drinnen nicht drehen dürfen
schickt er uns ein video sascha will das
land verlassen doch für männer unter 60
sind die grenzen zu
um über die grenze zu kommen muss man
die richtigen leute bestechen das können
sich nur die leisten die viel geld haben
die anderen müssen bleiben und kämpfen
sascha ist nicht alleine in einem keller
treffen wenn die kita und mascha auch
nikita glaubt dass er den kampf nicht
überleben würde deshalb will er weg doch
die bilder von seinem zuhause die hälte
nicht mehr aus
wo sollen wir denn das geld hernehmen um
das alles wieder aufzubauen ich habe
keine ahnung dafür hasse ich putin
in der küche sind anja und lisa auch sie
zeigen uns bilder zu hause in hartz iv
haben sie acht tage in einem
unterirdischen schutzraum ausgeharrt
sie haben unser zuhause in stücke
gerissen menschen ermordet kleine kinder
die die noch da sind können nicht mehr
auf die straße sie sind im keller wie
lebendig begraben das sind barbaren die
so was tun
es sind russen die das tun und die
schwestern haben wie viele ukraine
russische verwandte
die glauben und das gar nicht die
glauben den informationen in russland
und behaupten wir würden das alles nur
vorspielen wie schauspieler
wir rufen die an und weinen und die
lachen uns aus zurück zu sascha beim
fitnesstraining die mehrheit der männer
ist bereit zu kämpfen aber sascha zählt
zu denen die die welt nicht einteilen
wollen in west und ost und freund und
feind damit durchzukommen ist so was wie
ein drahtseilakt in einem land im krieg
flucht innerhalb der ukraine und heraus
aus der ukraine darüber möchte ich mit
gerald knaus reden migrationsforscher
mitbegründer des thinktanks europäische
stabilitäts initiative und er kennt die
ukraine sehr gut hat dort eine zeit lang
auch gelebt und in einer warnung an
einer universität unterrichtet genannten
aus guten abend vor slomka sie
prognostizieren ja wenn der krieg lange
so weitergeht dann könnten das am ende
sogar ja bis zu zehn millionen
flüchtlinge werden
naja was wir jetzt sehen ist leider für
jeden der putins kriege verfolgt hat
vertraut wir haben gesehen wie im don
was seit 2014 sehr viele menschen
vertrieben wurden wir haben gesehen wie
putins verbündete assad einen krieg
geführt hat wo jetzt mehr als ein
viertel der bevölkerung außerhalb
syriens ist wir haben gesehen wie putin
seinen ersten krieg in tschetschenien
geführt hat als er an die macht kam um
sowie der krieg jetzt geführt wird mit
städten wo menschen in den kellern
überleben müssen wo die
öffentliche versorgung zerstört wird und
wo klar wird dass diese menschen putins
herrschaft nie akzeptieren werden da
bleibt nur ein weg und der wäre so wie
bei assad darauf zu setzen dass
möglichst viele menschen fliehen und
wenn das passiert wenn auch aus der
ukraine ein viertel der menschen das
land verlassen dann wären das zehn
millionen menschen das ist leider keine
unrealistische erwartungen aus
routiniert gestoppt und auch teil einer
einer kriegsstrategie wir haben eben in
dem bericht aus lemberg gehört wie die
beiden jungen frauen erzählen dass man
sie mit verwandten in russland
telefonieren dass die ihnen das auch
nicht glauben was sie erleben also putin
scheint es ja wirklich zu schaffen große
teile der russischen bevölkerung mit
dieser dies information er komplett zu
verblenden wie schätzen sie das ein sie
waren ja auch häufig in russland haben
dort auch viele kontakte
ja leider ist das das ergebnis einer
längeren anstrengung diese propaganda in
den medien das aufbauen von feindbildern
die nationalistischen intellektuellen
und vor allem auch der raum für kritiker
es gibt ja viele russen die anders
denken
aber der raum für diese idee dieser
propaganda etwas entgegenhalten wollen
wurde immer kleiner und in den letzten
tagen ist er fast vollkommen
verschwunden das heißt jetzt gibt es nur
noch die botschaften der staatlichen
medien der der regierung des parlaments
das einstimmig drakonische strafen für
jede form von öffentlicher kritischer
debatte eingeführt hat diese woche und
das bedeutet die menschen haben eine
anderen quellen mehr einige wenige
erfahren vielleicht anderes über immer
kompliziertere wege aber wer ständig
hört dass es hier gegen die nazis geht
also gegen ein regime in kiew das von
einer
feindlichen eu von einer feindlichen
nato unterstützt wird der muss glauben
dass es hier einen krieg gegen das
absolut böse
dass hier krieg gegen das absolut böse
geführt wird und diese propaganda die
läuft in russland seit vielen jahren und
die war leider bis jetzt sehr
erfolgreich aber auch außerhalb
russlands gibt es erstaunlicherweise
jetzt zum beispiel in also für sie ist
das nicht erstaunlich sie haben auf dem
balkan
gelebt haben in sarajevo gelebt auch
kurz nach dem krieg in den 90er jahren
aber für viele andere ist es doch
überraschen dass es in serbien in
belgrad pro putin demonstrationen gibt
was sagt uns das reicht der lange arm
moskaus bis dorthin
ja auch auf dem balkan wobei es jedoch
immer die gelegenheit gebe wenn die
europäische union wenn deutschland und
frankreich diesmal versuchen vor die
welle zu kommen aber auch auf dem balkan
sehen wir seit einigen jahren dass das
was vor wenigen jahren noch undenkbar
schien nämlich neue konflikte neue
kriege kämpfe um grenzen dass das wieder
denkbar wird wir haben in den serbischen
medien auch seit einigen jahren
regelmäßig berichte über kriege wir
haben eine totale desinformation in den
medien in belgrad wird davon gesprochen
dass die ukraine russland angreift dass
russland demnächst truppen schickt das
auf dem balkan neue kriege ausbrechen
ich habe in bosnien bis vor einem jahr
keine politiker getroffen die sowie in
den letzten monaten offen darüber
sprechen in welchen polizeistationen
waffen sind und die erstmals nach über
zwei jahrzehnten neue gewalt fürchten
und hier ist es extrem wichtig für die
europäische union denn putin hat jedes
interesse durch provokationen neue
konflikte loszutreten dem
entgegenzutreten mit einer klaren
botschaft dass die sechs länder des
balkans eine perspektive haben nicht nur
hohle phrasen in dieses europa zu kommen
wo über grenzen eben nicht mehr
gestritten nicht mehr gekämpft kein blut
mehr vergossen wird weil grenzen
sichtbar werden wie heute eben zwischen
deutschland und polen also eine klare
perspektive an die bevölkerung und es
wäre gut wenn deutschland wenn
frankreich hier mit konkreten
botschaften an die bevölkerung aber auch
maßnahmen die das realistisch machen
möglichst schnell versuchen dieser
propaganda diesen nationalismus etwas
entgegenzusetzen und hier nicht
gutgläubig darauf vertrauen dass alles
schon am ende gut ausgeht das ja ist die
ukraine gescheitert herr klaus ich danke
ihnen für ihre einschätzungen und
analysen ich danke ihnen und putins
propagandamaschine greift im eigenen
land immer härter durch das trifft nicht
nur die russischen medien sondern jetzt
auch ausländische zahlreiche tv sender
darunter cnn die bbc auch hier unser zdf
und die ard haben ihre berichterstattung
aus russland vorerst ausgesetzt für
russische bürger und bürgerinnen ist es
extrem schwer geworden überhaupt noch
kritik zu äußern heraus sagte ist ja
gerade putin lässt er sogar kleine
kinder und alte frauen verhaften wenn
sie anti kriegs schilder hochhalten umso
bemerkenswerter dass sich dann doch
mehrere hundert russische
wissenschaftler letzte woche trauten
einen offenen protestbrief gegen den
krieg online zu stellen inzwischen haben
ihnen mehrere tausend unterschrieben
darüber berichtet sylvia bleßmann
russlands wissens elite zeigt sich
entsetzt über den angriffskrieg mit
einem friedensappell erheben mutige aus
der forschergemeinschaft ihre stimme
gegen die eigene staatsführung die
entfesselung des krieges für
geopolitische ambitionen seit zynischer
verrat an den vätern bewegende worte für
den deutschen physiker christian
spiering er hat sechs jahre in russland
gearbeitet die resolution gegen putins
krieg in seinem eigenen weltweiten
netzwerk veröffentlicht
juli ihnen natürlich immer noch viel zu
viele zu aber es gibt eben auch diese
leute und ich habe das wachsende liste
gesehen von 300 bis auf jetzt 6000 das
ist immer noch eine verschwindende
minderheit aber das macht mut und die
brauchen mut der mut den die beweisen
ist wirklich unglaublich
nur ein kleiner teil der 340.000
forschenden russland hat den deutlichen
anti kriegs appell unterzeichnet
der staat brot aktuell mit 15 jahren
haft für falschinformationen über die
russische armee das schüchtert 1
verunsichert
ascot ivan schick unterzeichnete schon
am ersten tag des krieges
ich kann beim picknick halt dann aber
kamen klar sagen das ist nicht in meinem
namen und natürlich die geheimdienste
machen ihre liste von alle leute die
solche die kreationen der zeichnung
haben aber jetzt finde ich ganz wichtig
dass wir können zeigen den westlichen
kollegen dass wir nicht eine politik von
booten unterstützen
deutsche universitäten haben kontakte zu
russland gekappt projekte gestoppt leer
und forschungskooperationen ausgesetzt
die etwa hat ihr verbindungsbüro in
moskau geschlossen stoppt alle
bewerbungen
das regime wird politisch nicht
unterstützt institutionell nicht
unterstützt und eben auch finanziell
nicht unterstützt da läuft jetzt kein
organisiertes geld rüber das heißt es
ist unterbrochen und ausgesetzt die
zusammenarbeit institutionell aber
individuell wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler sind miteinander in
kontakt und das soll auch so bleiben am
osteuropa institut der eu müssen die
uni-mitarbeiter die harten maßnahmen
nach russland kommunizieren wir denken
auch dass natürlich die beziehung grad
zur wissenschaft zu halten zu den
kollegen und kolleginnen wo wir auch
wissen wie sie denken ist eine ganz
wichtige sache die welt wird russische
forschende isolieren so lange ihrer
staatsführung täglich neue schreckliche
gründe liefert
viele aktuelle informationen finden sie
bei uns wie immer natürlich auch online
auf zdf heute und morgen früh dann ist
das morgenmagazin von 7 bis 9 uhr ein
spezial zur ukraine krieg und jetzt
macht erstmal heinz wolf weiter mit
weiteren nachrichten
us-außenminister interne blinken war
nach seinen gesprächen gestern in
brüssel heute in polen er dankte dem
land für das engagement innerhalb der
nato und bei der aufnahme
hunderttausende flüchtlinge aus der
ukraine blicken besuchte auch eine große
aufnahme unterkunft für geflüchtete mehr
als 800.000 menschen aus der
benachbarten ukraine haben seit beginn
der kämpfe bereits in polen schutz
gesucht und polens außenminister raus
sagte es würden auch weiterhin wir
versuchen den menschen aufgenommen
und wenn sie den menschen in der ukraine
und jenen auf der flucht helfen wollen
können sie spenden zum beispiel beim
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine bahn.de
65 104 106 100 104 106 100 alle infos
auch unter spenden zdf de oder im zdf
text auf seite 8 190
aus protest gegen den russischen angriff
sind in deutschland erneut zehntausende
auf die straße gegangen allein in
hamburg versammelten sich etwa 30.000
demonstranten um frieden in der ukraine
zu fordern größere kundgebungen gab es
unter anderem auch in düsseldorf und
münchen für morgen sind in zahlreichen
deutschen städten wieder demonstrationen
geplant
der ukraine krieg spielt jetzt auch
hinein in die internationalen
atomgespräche mit iran
bislang heißt es man stehe kurz vor
einer einigung um das atom abkommen von
2015 zu erneuern nun sprach russlands
außenminister lawrow von problemen er
verwies auf die jüngsten sanktionen des
westens und verlangte verbindliche
zusagen von den usa dass die im rahmen
des atom abkommens vereinbart und recht
der russlands zur zusammenarbeit mit
iran nicht beeinträchtigt würden
der ukraine krieg hat jedenfalls nicht
nur auswirkungen auf europa die art und
weise wie die ukraine überfallen wurde
dürfte weltweit die bestrebung und
verstärken sich atomwaffen zu
verschaffen und im asiatisch-pazifischen
raum fragt man sich vor allem welche
schlüssel china aus diesem krieg zieht
insbesondere fragen sich dass die
taiwaner der anspruch china sich taiwan
wieder einzuverleiben er ist schon lange
eine bedrohung jetzt ist diese sorge
noch aktueller geworden ist ein bericht
von ulf röller
der krieg in der ukraine beschäftigt
taiwans medien und das land beginnt sich
zu fürchten
in den talkshows diskutieren die
experten nun über einen angriff chinas
die bittere frage dabei ist das land
vorbereitet auf eine invasion wir
schauen uns die lage in der ukraine
genau an der verlauf des krieges hat uns
wachgerüttelt wir müssen uns wohl allein
verteidigen wir sollten uns nicht auf
hilfe aus dem ausland verlassen
us-präsident beiden schickte diese woche
eine delegation in die hauptstadt taipeh
um klar zu machen wir stehen an eurer
seite aber nicht nur die taiwanesische
präsidenten fragt sich wie weit würden
die usa gehen um taiwan zu verteidigen
die usa würden wohl alles einsetzen was
die diplomatischen ökonomisch zu bieten
haben um taiwan zu helfen aber sie
werden wohl nicht direkt mit china
militärisch kämpfen
in der region rüsten alle auf die
chinesen brauchen noch einige jahre laut
us sicherheitskreisen um militärisch
einen angriff riskieren zu können
die usa verstärken ihre militärübungen
in der region und taiwan modernisiert
seine streitkräfte seit jahren das
zusammenstehen des westens im ukraine
krieg macht taiwans für unmut
aber es ist klar dass das diese
handlungsfähigkeit der nato und auch der
europäischen union in der knallharten
sanktionierung von russland dass das
china beeindruckt china sieht das mit
sicherheit als warnung für die eigenen
vorgehensweisen in den nächsten jahren
chinas macht elite trifft sich zum
volkskongress zur taiwan frage gibt es
eine warnung an den westen preise den
skis regierungschef formuliert sehr
wir bekämpfen das streben nach
unabhängigkeit und jegliche einmischung
des auslands
alle augen sind auf präsident ski
gerichtet er hat sich mit putin vereint
er nennt dessen invasion eine
spezialoperation
aber der angriff in der ukraine dauert
wohl nach chinesischen geschmack zu
lange
zeit wohl nicht vor gewalt zurück das
teilt er mit putin aber er kann warten
bis der westen wieder einmal wegschaut
wenn
es eine günstige gelegenheit geben
sollte wenn die usa abgelenkt sind etwa
wenn die nicht mehr militärisch
außenpolitisch handlungsfähig sind dann
wird es sehr konkret werden dass in
china ein zugriff auf treiber neben wird
sie wird ende des jahres wohl auf
lebenszeit zum präsidenten ernannt er
beobachtet die demokratische welt ob sie
bereit ist den preis der freiheit zu
bezahlen
im moment jedenfalls steht der westen
und das vielleicht auch deutlicher und
härter als putin erwartet hatte zu den
neuen entwicklungen des tages gehört ja
dass der israelische regierungschef
heute in moskau war und jetzt am abend
in berlin eingetroffen ist frage an theo
koll bringt sich da israel als
vermittler ins spiel
ganz offensichtlich also wir hören dass
es bei den gesprächen mit putin um den
versuch einer waffenruhe ging es vor
wenigen minuten hier mit dem
hubschrauber im kanzleramt eingetroffen
und dazu muss man wissen dass israel
trotz seiner großen nähe zur schutzmacht
usa
überraschend neutral geblieben ist in
diesem konflikt und daher vielleicht
durchaus als vermittler geeignet ist das
land hat nicht nur eine große russland
stämmige gemeinde st es braucht im nahen
osten auch immer wieder die
stillschweigende unterstützung von
russland denn insbesondere beim kampf
gegen pro-iranische milizen in syrien
und deswegen hat sich israel mit kritik
an russland bisher sehr zurückgehalten
hat sich auch den sanktionen gegen putin
nicht angeschlossen gleichzeitig hat
israel gute kontakte zur ukraine auch
dort gibt es eine große jüdische
gemeinde präsident zielinski selbst
jüdischen glaubens und hat israel auch
gebeten sich als ort für
friedensgespräche anzubieten kritiker
haben bennett vorgeworfen mit dieser
vermittlungsrolle seine unentschiedene
haltung über spielen zu wollen und auch
der ukrainische präsident war zuletzt
enttäuscht über israels zurückhaltung
unter anderem weil man die gewünschten
waffen nicht liefern wollte aber
möglicherweise kommt ja durch diesen
besuch bewegung rein
franke abend noch im kanzleramt
dankeschön
angesichts der ukraine kriegs gehen
andere themen im moment ja ziemlich
unter was aber nicht heißt dass es sie
nicht mehr gibt corona etwa in
deutschland steigen die zahlen aktuell
wieder in österreich auch trotzdem wird
dort jetzt weiter geöffnet heißt ja dort
sind heute fast alle corona regeln
weggefallen so gibt es unter anderem
keine zugangsbeschränkungen in
gaststätten oder hotels mehr würde
hauptstadt wien hält an einigen
maßnahmen fest
bundesgesundheitsminister lauterbach hat
derweil vor einer corona welle im sommer
gewarnt der funke mediengruppe sagte er
selbst bei gutem wetter könnten die
infektionen wieder zunehmend wenn es gar
keine einschränkungen mehr gebe aktuell
registriert das rk ii den dritten tag in
folge steigende zahlen binnen 24 stunden
wurden 192
1210 neuinfektionen gemeldet 16
1377 mehr als vor einer woche
255 todesfälle kamen hinzu die sieben
tage incidents steigt auf 1.200
20,8 und
jetzt die lottozahlen dieses samstag sie
lauten wie immer ohne gewähr
22 25 26 28
41 superzahl 0 weitere gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto punkt zdf de und
zdf text auf seite 5 56 und auch die
wetteraussichten für morgen im norden
und osten teils dichte wolken sonst
freundliche mischung aus sonne und
wolken höchstwerte 18 grad die weiteren
aussichten auch in der neuen woche oft
sonnig höchstens im norden und osten
auch mal dichter bewölkt montag zwei bis
neun grad danach allmählich etwas milder
das war es im heute journal an diesem
samstagabend mit dem aktuellen
sportstudio geht es weiter und danach 0
40 gibt es dann die nächste heute
express es morgen nach wiedersehen
wiedersehen
[Musik]